[Applause]
this is
we're doing this barack obama bit like
they would film us and then say action
and we become the great and then we say
cut and then we would go right back into
doing obama and the crew was so sick of
it
the idea was that he was at the base of
the capitol records building talking to
a ton of people
just talking about his time today i went
to amiibo records
yeah i went down to i went down to
venice beach
we're in the 60s a band taught us that
if we work hard
we can break on through to the other
side
but joe wears the biggest mask i've ever
seen
and he's standing like 200 feet away
from everybody oh
look man i'm a nice guy
but if you give me any more guff tonight
i'll rip your face off like a mad
chimp i'll knock that thing off your
head and
burn it bury it in the pet cemetery
where it came from
stop it joe stop it clinton was so
smooth
he could lie his way out of anything he
could stand in front of you right now
look you all directly in the eyes and
say i
am not here
what is here isn't here just there
without a t
if the monica lewinsky scandal happened
to president bush there's no way he gets
out of it
put him on the stand mr president you
have relations with that woman monica
lewinsky
what did they tell me to say here
[Applause]
that was out loud wasn't it
i cannot believe i said that there's two
kinds of words inside words and outside
words
[Applause]
inside words stay in outside words come
out that time and inside word popped out
gobble gobble it's great to see you guys
today you're doing a tremendous job and
may i say right off the bat pierce it's
great to have you out of that evil cnn
and back where you belong in london and
the beautiful susanna
i am going to reinstitute reinstitute
my beauty pageants because you look
tremendous today
let's move on to uh to former president
nixon yeah um
right next wait till i get into erection
next
how long does this take as long as i
need
well before we lose you are you planning
a comeback
well first of all let me say this i i
want to make this perfectly clear
i am making a comeback i've been out
i've been away too long
as a matter of fact abc is thinking of
hiring me to do a few game shows
on television next season as the host
and
i i don't know which one i'm gonna do uh
perhaps uh to tell the truth
or tattletail or maybe
let's make a deal
will you film these for no no no these
these will be on
tape you see then if i don't like
something i can snip it out and burn the
damn thing
charles plays funniest movie i've ever
seen in life
i left so hard i pee i pee pants i
someone was killed by the little doll
and it wasn't me who did that was look
at me it wasn't me
it was the doll anyway you should go see
little chucky
uh in toy story four it's ratata so i
did obama for obama
and i looked at him and i was like what
do you think he was like uh well you did
pretty good
amazing uh you sound just like i do
and now i'm gonna need you to take over
because this job is stressful
[Applause]
but my favorite my favorite politician
by far was always
ronald reagan
[Applause]
who the hell are you
you know i had a pretty good career
considering the fact that i didn't even
finish college
and a reporter over at the times found
out about this
and he asked me point blank he said mr
president
were you a dropout i said what
he said were you a dropout i said no
no i i was cesarian
you know because you know i've never
done this before man
but you know joe biden man he always
seems like he's reaching for something
because he knows
the words the words are going to escape
him but
i put my hand up like i'm trying to
reach and get him back
and you're with me right i'm pretty much
a 90s r b singer watch this
i love you come on come on man it's very
interesting the way you look at this
stuff
i actually i was staying in lincoln
bedroom last night and i couldn't resist
getting on the phone and i called up the
secret service as the president
feel like gone jogging tonight
in the nude
my wife and i were looking on the lawn
or at midnight these guys were
fully unclogged
well it's good to have i've been
studying him since yesterday and i think
i've actually
the way to do the president is to start
out with mr rogers it's a beautiful day
in the neighborhood then you add a
little john wayne here we go let's go
over the ridge you put them together you
got
george herbert walker bush
that's the thing there
now remember when he went to the berlin
wall and he said he was like he was very
plain spoken mr gorbachev
tear down this wall that was very clear
very dramatic obama would say something
like uh we believe that barriers of any
kind act as an obstruction to people's
good relationships
what the are you talking about do you do
trump as well
yes of course listen jimmy the people
jimmy the people love me trump but
the people do okay joe listen joe
somebody say something to joe
joe shut up joe you're lying joe because
the people love me jimmy it's all about
the people
fact check black twitter the people love
me i've done more for black people
since michael jackson the people love me
they really do they love me
[Applause]
the guy that really cracks me up is um
uh
president bush
i think it's great we have a president
who seems like he's always looking
directly into the sun
somebody do me a favor and hand me a
pair of sunglasses
somebody get me a visor
first you mean adviser no adviser
[Applause]
what are you stupid and he's the
only person i've ever seen do this when
he talks
[Applause]
i've seen turkeys do that
i'm always going to watch him always
waiting for him to go gobble gobble
right what i truly love is when he gets
something right because when our
president
gets something right he is the happiest
man
on earth he gets that little smile on
his face that i can't believe that came
out correctly smile
it's like a fan is blowing on him two or
three hundred miles an hour he's not
getting rid of world hunger he's just
getting all the way through the sentence
and he's content
right i feel like and that's why the
united states
will lead us all to peace
now i've done a lot of politicians over
the years i've done people like
like bill clinton who wrote me a lot of
great material
[Music]
and george w bush i don't know why the
american people are
picking on me
i haven't done anything
you're still buddies with president
clinton aren't you yes
now do you do you do that when you're
around him oh he loves it
he in fact uh while we were shooting we
shoot in baltimore
and he he came down there because he had
to give a speech so he asked me if i
wanted to come with him and i said sure
so he said well why don't you just put
your car behind the motorcade
so so we're driving through the streets
of baltimore with the police motorcade
and secret service and
and then he went oh i want some coffee
i think there's a starbucks up ahead
so we pulled over to starbucks
by the way i think he's got more
coverage than his speech we pulled over
to starbucks
and we went inside starbucks and the
whole place sort of went crazy the
former president united states is there
and all he got was like a decaf coffee
i think if you're going to go to
starbucks to get like a frappuccino oh
yeah oh
something that was at the end of the
evening or was it just a stop oh no we
stopped and we talked to people there
yeah you know he loves to talk to people
hi i see he loves play cards
and you like playing hearts big hearts
like oh oh hearts
oh yeah and i think somewhere along the
way he must have taken a pill
that says i don't go to bed so there's
no one left to talk to